Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here we have a guest,
Jason Philipa,
crossfit games champion,
and we're going to talk about a few things that perhaps need clarification and
I'm personally interested to know about warm ups.
So how do you typically take your athletes through warmups and maybe even what
are some common mistakes that people make in their warm ups?
Yeah,
I mean I would,
I would kind of put it two fold.
I think number one,
one of the concerns,
we see what the warmup is where people don't have any guidance and direction or
focus on what they want to do.
And so the purpose behind the warmup is pretty simple.
It's get your core body temperature up,
take your body through a full range of motion,
right?
Get you prepare.
Let's just say you just got out of the car where you just got a bed.
Can I take your bike through the full range of motion?
But most importantly also start preparing different movement patterns there'll
be incorporating for your workout,
right?
An example would be today we had a class doing pull ups or or box jumps for
example.
So one of the things I want to make sure that we're doing box jumps in the work
of the day is to make sure we're opening up the hamstring,
making sure open up the Achilles,
opening up areas that are going to be specifically tax during that workout.
And so an example of a warmup that's just a good general warmup.
What I like to do is like to go into the garage,
you're going to the gym,
started a timer and as soon as you start the timer when it does is it gives you
the sense of urgency.
I think sometimes what happens is the warmup ends up taking an hour.
The warm just needs to take a little bit of time,
10 15 minutes,
kind of prep the body and obviously it depends on what you're doing.
But my recommendation is set a clock right after you set the clock.
Sorry folks,
yon kind of big movers,
meaning like a rower,
getting that cardio,
big big movers running,
uh,
squatting,
right?
Full range of motion,
things that really take you through a full range of motion in joints like
thrusters,
right?
All the way down.
All the way up,
shoulder presses,
those types of things.
And what CEI does a good squat warmup look like?
Yeah,
I mean as far as I'm considered,
one of the things I like to do is I like to grab onto a pull,
right?
Or something to get like uh,
uh,
components and feedback.
And we're not going to do is I have to get down in the squat right?
And at the bottom of like to kind of work through the positions,
kind of opened up my hips,
getting this position,
we're really focusing on the crease of my hip below my knee joint at this point.
So I'm holding the pole and kind of open myself up.
Once I feel like my ankles are opening up,
my hips are opening up,
then I start working through kind of a slow squat.
And what I focused on is you can go up against the wall,
you can go up against the pole,
whatever.
But I think about key my arms up therefore engages my lower back.
Right?
So I'm thinking about three things.
My low back is flat,
my weight is in my heels and I'm trying to get the crease of my hip below my
knee joint to really work that full range sweater.
They squat down,
right?
I'm really focused on tight back,
wait my heels that can,
I get that power and the crease that will need joint to work that full range.
Then as I'm Kinda grooving and feeling it out,
I started dragging my knees out.
I go slow,
slow,
really perfected.
Then I start adding the speed.
Right.
Then I started getting in reps and what I'll do is I'll,
you know,
I'll look at the clock and I'll do maybe five squats,
five sit ups,
five pushups for about two minutes.
Kind of getting the body moving and going through those patterns.
And uh,
when you then move to using say a barbell in the squat because I,
the,
the squat being I suppose one of the higher yield activities so that you can
focus on,
uh,
how do you typically do back squats or instruct people to do back squats with a
bar?
With a barbell?
Yeah,
I mean with the Barbell,
I mean essentially it's the same points of performance,
right?
So when we talk about the back squat,
we talk about the squat,
one thing about points performance and what are those really going to be?
Right?
We want our weight plants in our heel to make sure we're engaging kind of our
glutes,
our hamstrings,
et cetera.
We want our torso and our,
our our lower back nice and tight and we never want to see this thing kind of
break here or overextend want the crease for a hip or knee joint.
When our knees out,
now we grab onto the bar.
Some of the things that I'm thinking about right?
His hand placement and foot placement.
So I'll walk up to the bar and I'll think right hand left hand whether I have
just the Barbell,
a hundred pounds,
200 pounds,
400 pounds.
I want to set up the same way.
I want to have some type of a mantra in my head where I have some type of
rhythm.
So this way when I get into a competition setting or or a heavier load,
my brain is already been trained to do so.
Right?
So his right hand left hand and you do typically space.
Yeah.
It's sort of an inch in or out on the knurling for myself.
And this is all,
you know,
there's some that's that's personal preference,
right?
But some of the non negotiables are,
you know,
flat back in the hills,
et cetera.
But as far as in this,
uh,
sometimes people with poor shoulder mobility need to go a little bit wider.
So let's just say I'm in this position,
right?
Right foot,
left foot.
I come underneath the bar.
I address it now as like Getty here.
Right now it's level of my traps.
Some people do a low bar back squat.
You do a low bar,
then I why not my grip.
But for me,
I like to go high bar.
So I placed,
it happened my traps now before I even pick it up,
right?
I'm thinking,
Hey,
if I just pick it up kind of with my low back,
rounded and had crappy position,
I can mess myself up and it feels heavier than needs to be.
So at four I haven't lifted up.
It's a big breath.
Boom.
I pick it up with kind of like a a purpose,
right?
Purpose before I even lift off the bar.
Now from this position is the exact same thing,
right?
I'm focusing on key components.
My chest is up,
I'm gazing straight ahead.
I sit back into my heels,
right crease of my hip goes below my knee,
joints,
elbows are in this good position,
chest is up,
boom.
I drive back out of it,
right?
And then as a re re rack it,
I walk into the wreck.
Sometimes people,
they use the rack the wrong way.
For me,
the best part I like to do is I like to back out of the rack and then come back
into the rack.
This one,
when you're fatigued,
you're easily,
he will just put it right back in.
So meaning I,
I noticed you put your feet in a good deal further than a lot of people do when
you were loading yourself up with the weight.
And then when you're coming in,
meaning you're basically using forward momentum to place it back on the,
yeah,
I mean a little bit,
right?
I mean,
you know,
obviously it also depends on how much load you're doing.
Right?
And but yes,
for the most part the big is on the backs.
What is,
is kind of,
uh,
addressing the bar with purpose.
I think a lot of times people,
the backs,
why is a,
is a foundational movement that should beautiful because it's stressed your
entire system,
right?
So you're just getting strong from head to toe.
I mean,
tax,
if you had to ask me one movement that you could do twice a week to increase
pure strength,
I would say it more than likely be the back squat.
Right now I'm on a program,
I started off on a five by five.
I go up 10 pounds once a week.
Right.
But I do it or twice a week,
depending on if you want to go five pound jumps each one.
But these use on a linear progression.
That's one example of a strength component you get incorporated.
Why are you doing five by five crew?
So I'm going to find my five currently just because I've tried different things.
So I've done 20 right back squat,
I've done,
I've done when there's five,
three,
one,
I've done all different types of stuff.
For me,
the five by five is nice because I could warm up to a weight final load.
Let's just say it's a hundred pounds and then I know that I'm gonna be able to
get in and out quickly.
You know,
I'm done with my sets in 30 minutes.
It's,
it's a,
it's a weight that's challenging but not so crazy.
I'm going to feel like I'm gonna injure myself.
But most importantly is time under tension.
So five reps just down,
up,
down,
right?
And it's just that time and attention gets you stronger and it over time you
increase the load.
So this way you make sure your technique is on point.
And how long will that five by five period last for you?
Is it,
is it a set period?
Is it three months?
Is it four months is it's,
so right now I'm going up in 10 pound increments,
right?
I'm actually personally,
I'm,
I'm starting off right now once week 10 Penn in Cummins because have a lot other
stuff going on.
I recommend for most people to maybe do twice a week,
right?
But maybe do it five pound jumps,
et cetera.
Now,
what will happen for me as I'm gonna go 10 pounds up,
now I'm gonna get to a point where I could no longer complete those five reps.
Then what I'll do is I'll go ahead and revert back to about two,
two sessions before and then I'll start going up in five pound increments.
And then once I can no longer do that,
then I'll go ahead and reevaluate and drop back down and then keep going up.
And,
but the,
the,
the key for me is where I'm at in my life.
I want you to stay strong.
I don't need to be super strong.
I don't need a back squat 500 pounds.
I just went back squat 400 pounds and I'm okay with that.
Yeah.
And uh,
how much in terms of rescue you taking between the fiber upsets you want
recovery and so that's can be a little bit different.
I think sometimes we need time.
The stats,
you know,
for me it's probably a one-to-one.
Like I'll,
I'll play,
I'll hit us set.
Let's just say it takes on a 30 seconds,
then would all wait on is probably maybe not one to one.
It probably maybe two minutes.
Right?
I want to feel recovered and they hit it again.
Obviously it depends on how much load there is,
right?
I mean,
if I'm starting off at 300 pounds,
it's a lot different than when I get up to 400 pounds.
Right.
You need more time to let your system reset and that's just feeling it out.
And is your preference when say you were making this 10 pound jumps and then
you're unable to complete the five reps?
Uh,
the preference is to decrease the,
the size of the jumps in the increments.
Uh,
do you play with the interval between workouts as well or do you keep that
standard?
You mean the rest period or you mean and how the number holes?
Oh yeah.
I play with it.
All right.
I mean,
the thing about it is,
is that I think people sometimes get too caught up in their program.
The program is only as good as how well you execute on it,
right?
As long as you have an idea that hey,
once or twice a week I need to squat heavy,
I need to go down and up with a heavy load on my back,
you're going to get stronger.
Right.
We don't need get to too wrapped up.
Now if you find a program,
stick with it and I think that's really important.
Meaning to re evaluate often.
Right.
Maybe some days you're not feeling it,
maybe do it in the next day.
Right.
But you the last thing you want to do.
I think sometimes people get into these rhythms when they find a program that
had just become super diligent on it,
which I totally respect.
The problem is sometimes they go in and let's just say the coaches programmed
some crazy workout,
but they were up all night with their kid,
they were sick,
whatever.
Now they go in,
they have a halfass workout cause they feel like crap and they look at their
results and it makes them feel worse.
Instead they should have gone in than an active recovery day and came in
tomorrow and done it.
So you need to listen to your body.
And what are some of the biggest mistakes that you see with novice or
intermediate?
Uh,
athletes or recreational say crossfitters or otherwise when they're trying to
pick a program?
Yeah,
I think picking up,
I think the biggest problem we see is that they're trying to jump from program
to program,
think he's going to get them results when in reality we'll get your results is
hard work.
And that's the biggest problem that I see fundamentally with a lot of the guys
that are coming in the crossfit space.
It'll jump from this program in this program,
this program,
they'll do it alone in the garage instead of trying to get into the gym.
Do with buddies,
you know,
push each other hard,
right?
And get in this atmosphere that breeds results.
And so the most critical pieces put yourself in a position of success.
And the best way I think you do that is by surrounding yourself.
Other people that are going to elevate you.
Um,
program aside.
Now,
do you need an okay program?
Sure.
But the difference between doing 80%,
82% is almost irrelevant as long as you're going in there and you're attacking
it with purpose.
And I'm sure there are a lot of people out here and there are a lot of people
out there who think they're working really hard.
Right?
So to you,
what does that mean?
That's a really good question.
I think that there's a lot of people who think they're working hard and the are
working hard.
They're probably working harder than most people in the United States,
right?
But I think having a coach and a community around you will always take you to
another level.
And it's very hard to argue otherwise.
Like,
I've worked out in my garage for years.
But what I find is you really need to have the clock to motivate you or your
friends.
Meaning I like to do email moms,
so every minute on the minute,
so each minute I give myself a goal and I need to hit it.
So now it's almost like my friend is the clock and I'm competing against the
clock,
right?
Like,
Hey,
I want to get 10 back squats in a minute,
whatever.
But you always need to have something to kind of shoot for when you're in the
gym.
You have this,
this atmosphere,
this sense of camaraderie that I think pushes you.
So I think what it is is it's when you're done with the workout,
you evaluate,
you sit there and you ask yourself this very simple question,
did I do the best I could not work out that I really go hard?
And if the answer is yes,
great,
the answer is no.
Then fixed it the next day.
But I think sometimes people wait too long to ask themselves that question,
right?
For,
for people who were say semi athletic,
uh,
in their twenties or thirties,
getting into say crossfit style workouts for the first time.
Okay.
Haven't played any competitive sports in a long time.
Right.
And uh,
you're looking at their first year of training.
Are there any particular movements you would remove or warnings that you would
make so that they avoid injury?
I think the most important thing is we've done a lot of people from,
you know,
formal,
former NFL players to this,
to that,
whatever the,
the yet to be coachable and you have to be prepared to be okay with going a
little bit lighter.
And I think one of the problems,
and I've had the same thing happened to me,
is that sometimes you need to take a step back,
take a step forward.
And if you build the house on a,
on a,
you know,
on some strong foundation you could do a really good job.
But I think sometimes in the first year of crossfit,
people have this tendency to want to go up and go up and go up when they,
their movement isn't efficient,
but they're getting away with because they're muscling.
It's like Jujitsu,
right?
Yeah.
In Jujitsu is the exact same thing.
Yes,
I can try and muscle it,
but I can maybe do that with a white belt.
But as soon as I get to a certain level where someone else's whatever,
I'm not gonna be able to muscle it anymore.
And so if I build the foundation today about technique first,
right?
Make sure I can do it well once,
make sure my mechanics are on point,
right?
Then they share.
I can consistently do it right.
Can I,
can I perform the basketball consistently?
Well with no low,
just kind of warming up then.
All right,
let's dose it.
But let's hit it hard.
And,
uh,
in say that first year,
let's,
I'll give you a hypothetical.
So let's say you have 150 pounds to make the math.
It's kind of easy.
150 pound former athlete.
So high school athlete,
not college.
Right.
Okay.
Still in reasonably good shape isn't like eating hohos and right and
cheeseburgers every meal every day and wants to set some goals.
And so I think a lot of people,
certainly speaking for myself,
are motivated by having a clear objective.
Absolutely.
And so this guy comes to you and says,
what should Mike,
what do you,
what do you suggest is goals sort of at the end of year one?
Is it like back squat,
x times body weight and then this and then that and the other thing.
What were some goals?
How it potential goals?
I would probably look at power lifts and conditioning or gymnastics pieces
before I looked at Olympic lifts,
done it.
That's what I would do.
The Olympic lifts are highly complex,
right?
They develop many different general physical skills from neurological components
to physical adaptations.
I mean,
it's a phenomenal lips,
but they're like a golf swing,
you know,
anybody could swing a golf club or expand your entire life trying to perfect it.
The Olympic lifts to the same.
So my recommendation would be not to rush that.
Right.
That process takes time.
But with things like the power lifts,
you know,
you can get on a program and increase your back squat tremendously over the
stage.
Squat,
deadlift,
bench,
squat,
deadlift.
I mean those are the Kings,
right?
I mean push,
pull,
squat,
right,
right.
And in addition to obviously have cardiovascular type things your mile time,
uh,
you know,
can you do a muscle up,
right?
There's a good example.
Um,
you know,
can do pull ups,
those are easy targets that you can shoot for.
We can get on programs to do it and I like doing every minute on the minute work
to accomplish that.
So for example,
if I wanted to get better at pullups,
one of the things that I've done the past is,
you know,
five strict pull ups,
right?
Every minute on the minute for 10.
So you just allocate 10 minutes to come in your garage and do five every minute
for 10 minutes.
Then as you start progressing,
he's not,
it gets easier,
maybe start doing chest to bar.
Then as that starts getting easier,
maybe you increase the numbers and then over time we end up finding is your pool
of strength will get significantly better and it's not at the,
um,
it's not the,
uh,
the technique is still on point,
right?
Whereas the Olympic lifts,
you're so focused on increasing,
increasing,
increasing.
If your position is incorrect,
you'll eventually hit a dead end and with say that 150 pounds cmis athletic,
former competitive guy,
uh,
any particular goals in the power lifts that you had said?
If he's like,
I just need a number or something in mind that I can hold in place as an
objective by the end of the year,
if,
uh,
I mean,
double,
double body weight back squat is,
uh,
you know,
it's a very achievable goal,
but it's a challenging goal,
right?
Um,
triple bodyweight deadlift is,
is,
is pretty extreme,
right?
Two and a half times is,
is,
is pretty good.
Obviously there's exceptions is if you're a specialist,
right?
But you know,
and then you talk about like a bench press,
I dunno,
two,
one and a half times body weight,
right?
You start talking about these numbers,
Sure.
But in theory we want to think about is how is my overall fitness looking like,
you know,
I'm the guy where,
I've ran a five 40 mile and I've backed school,
had the same day,
you know,
for 50 that's,
that was my goal.
But there's some guys like,
like our buddy Mark Bell who wants to swag squat 1000 pounds but can't run 400
meters.
He probably can,
but it'll take them awhile.
You may not a good time or just period good time.
But you know,
that's why you know,
the people,
you don't evaluate their goals.
Right.
And,
and,
and see what they're trying to do.
For me it's a blend of all these different things cause then they carry over
into so many different things.
You know,
I can go mountain biking,
I can go snowboarding,
I can go Jujitsu,
I don't need to worry about it.
Right.
But if I was only lifting or only doing cardio,
I wouldn't have those carryovers.
And you mentioned gymnastic.
So the powerlifting components and gymnastic components before say Olympic
lifts.
Yeah,
you can do them all simultaneously.
No,
totally.
But I'm wondering within the gymnastic components,
which do you think have the,
our foundational or have the most carryover to many other things?
Yeah,
I mean,
that's a great question.
I think in the gymnastics realm,
and so I think a good program combines,
you know,
powerlifting,
gymnastics,
um,
you know,
obviously your traditional cardiovascular types and then the Olympic lifts are
beautiful because they've just put it all together.
Now,
gymnastics in particular,
I think the pushup is a staple,
right?
You should be able to do a pushup in a good position,
Where you're in a good elbow position where it's very practical,
right.
On pressing this way.
I'm pressing this way,
I'm pressing this way in a dip.
Right?
Can we see what a good pushup looks like versus,
I mean,
in theory,
right?
A lot of people in,
they do their up,
they love to kind of push it up through all those.
Right?
Now that position,
right,
puts some strain on the shoulder.
And what it also does is it's not functional,
right?
Imagine if your car had gas.
You wouldn't push like this.
Right?
And so in theory,
what we're really thinking about is here my head goes forward a little bit,
my elbows stay more or less in.
Now this transfer here,
right transfers into things like,
right.
He hands the hand,
right?
A transfers into a dip transfer is all these different things.
So that's the position we're looking for.
And how do you develop that?
Obvious you can do on your knees,
your head comes forward.
My body stays rigid,
my elbows,
Stan.
That's a great way to develop it.
Got It.
So you're doing it like a very mild,
not a plan Shlain exactly.
But you're,
you're rocking your entire body weight forward slightly so that your forums or
more.
That's right.
Which gets me not tripod position and use for handstand pushups.
The tripod head forward,
hands back.
What's a,
you mentioned Mark Bell.
What are,
what are some of the things that you've learned by hanging out with Mark Bell in
other top tier power lifters?
What are some of the things that you've served incorporated for yourself or
learned?
I mean those guys,
you know,
Mark Bell,
the Louie Simmons of the world,
I mean these guys just,
you know,
I remember not eight years ago,
you don't,
I'm a young guy.
I Walk in Louie Simmons Gym and there's five guys back squatting,
you know,
800 pounds.
One is bleeding out their nose.
And what I learned from that experience,
right is that what you said is that I was at Westside barbell is just the
dedication to the craft.
Right?
And that's inspiring.
Well,
no matter what you do is the dedication to the craft,
right?
If you're a Barista would be really good at it.
So in Mark's really good at is he's really good at his craft and then obviously
in his craft,
his passion for coaching is really inspiring for me.
And then obviously his ability to then transfer that into helping people improve
their lifts is,
is,
is really great.
Cause that's what inspires me.
What,
uh,
what have you observed?
What makes them a good coach?
Because I mean,
you're a very good coach.
So what,
what makes,
when you've watched mark,
you're like,
hmm.
Kind of taking mental notes or observing what he's doing.
Right.
What makes them a good coach?
And then the second part,
which you can answer first if you want,
is as it relates to the power lifts,
are there any particular technical modifications or programming thoughts,
anything that you've,
uh,
borrowed or tested from some of those guys?
I mean,
I would see what,
what makes him a good coach is that he comes off as authentic,
right?
He practices what he preaches,
which I think is very important.
Um,
and he comes off like he really cares legitimately about getting that person's
movement better.
But most importantly is that he's also open minded enough to recognize that
there's different systems,
different body types,
different whatever.
And he's not judging people.
He's just saying,
hey,
give us a shot.
It might not be for everybody,
but give us a shot.
Right.
And I think that's what's really inspiring because you have some of these people
who are at the top of their game and they said,
no,
we have to do it this way.
It's like,
well,
what if my femur is too long or whatever.
You know,
and I think that's what's really cool about mark as a kind of,
you know,
takes whatever you can from each person and incorporates it.
And I think in regards to technique,
you know,
you see people set up from the delta,
from the top,
set up from the bottom,
do different types of things,
and then you say,
set up,
what do you mean by that?
Really just brace a position,
right?
Shoulder,
back,
position,
brace,
belly.
Everything's engager at peak tension,
right?
Some people,
uh,
you know,
connect here,
reach down,
grab and just go right?
Some people for me,
right?
I like to step in and dealt a little bit different.
I to go down to the delivery,
Kenneth,
have a rounded back,
have a rounded position.
Then right before I'm ready to go right in this position,
I set everything.
Boom.
I set the back,
I set the shoulders,
I pulled a bar in,
I'm tightening lats and I lift.
That's what I like to do.
Um,
and so really looking at mark and in different types of people as you pick up on
these techniques.
But most importantly is just the foundation of movement.
It's underload never move your spine.
That's,
I mean,
that's a critical piece.
Whether you're pressing overhead,
you're,
you're doing a deadlift or you're squatting.
Once you connect head to hip,
just stay there.
Got It.
So that orientation should not change.
That's right.
Whatever orientation that is.
Right.
So let's just say you're here and maybe your back has a slight,
maybe your thoracics little rounded from st the computer too long or whatever,
right.
Hold that position obviously is not favorable.
Try and work for a better position,
but whatever you do,
just hold it there because as soon as you start moving that spinal or load,
all of a sudden the load finds that,
that,
that tension position and you start,
you know,
putting yourself more at risk of injury started bending the paper clip in ways
you shouldn't been.
The paper clip.
That's right.
What are some keys to,
let's say you have a,
a dead lifter.
Yeah.
It,
who is pulling three 15 in a sort of a,
not a super wide sumo stance but sort of uh,
uh,
it's like Ed coan moderate,
yeah.
Moderate stance and he's,
he pulled three 15 buddies.
He's hit that point where it's like,
I can't make more than five reps with three 15.
Uh,
what points would you look to tweak or experiment with,
uh,
to help that person if you believe that they could get to say 400 or beyond?
I mean it,
when they were trying to guess,
it might not be a great question.
I would say also just generally speaking,
like what are the,
the keys to the deadlift and when you have somebody starting with the deadlift,
do you start them conventional sumo,
a Hex Bar?
If it depends what,
how does it,
how do you determine that?
I just love to hear.
I,
I'm fascinated by the deadlift.
So for us,
any thoughts on the deadline for us at our gym,
right.
Nc Fit,
we always start,
we always start conventional.
And the reason why I like conventionalist cause the carryover into the clean and
the snatch.
So is there anything wrong as to Modelo?
Absolutely not.
Right?
Plenty of lifters lift that way,
but for us,
we like the conventional stance because it carries over into the clean.
It carries over into the snatch,
right?
That's what we like it.
Now,
what I would say to this gentleman that stuck at three 15 is yes,
I look at his position.
So one of the things I look at right is when he's in this position,
is he in this position or is he creating that peak tension on the hamstring by
really engaging it by pointing his knees back and as he stands,
he really pointing his knees back,
or is it kind of going up and around?
Right?
I look for those type of things,
right?
He is he getting the most out of his hamstrings that he can.
And then the next thing I would do is start looking at,
you know,
different types of components to start building up those strengths,
whether it be deficit,
dead lifts,
right?
At lighter loads,
whether it'd be banded deadlifts,
whether it be changed.
Let's explain.
So depths that dead lift would be when you elevate your feet so that you're
going lower than usual.
And that's a really valuable tool specifically for the Olympic lifts as well.
So one of the things that's very challenging about the Olympic lifts,
the most important thing about the Olympic lifts is holding positions,
right?
So when you're off the floor and your Olympic lifting,
right when you're here,
as I drive up,
my only goal until I get to here is to maintain the ratio for my head to hit.
And this whole contact point.
Now the problem is as the weight gets heavier,
right?
This wants to pull you forward.
This wants around your back.
This wants to kind of make you do one of these and see you have to resist that
change.
One of the ways you can incorporate that,
assuming you get hold,
good spine position with your hamstrings,
flexibility is to stand on top of the plate and now you go from a little bit
lower,
right?
But that's a good training drill for the deadlift is from a deficit position.
If you have the flexibility that position to do so.
So you mentioned a few things that I want to touch on because I think they're
super important.
So we were talking about the push up a little earlier and you,
you observed rather than flaring your elbows out,
which has very little transferred to other movements you wanted to have,
you want to mimic a position that you will then be able to use in other types of
movements and sports.
So for the deadlift,
uh,
it seems like you're assessing a very similarly where you're asking what is the
depth of position that will give us the greatest degree of transfer for other
movements?
Yeah.
That we find valuable.
Uh,
what are some other mistakes that people make with exercises such as flaring the
elbows out in the pushup?
Are there other common mistakes where you look at it and you're like a not a
very stable position that B,
it's not going to help you in the other 12th things we want to get good at?
I'd say mostly,
I would say the biggest one answer your question has range of motion.
That's the biggest one.
When we talk about range of motion,
whether it be uh,
you know,
and here's an important thing to kind of kick kick to,
people who are listening to this is that I would look at movements that move a
large load,
a long distance quickly that carry a barbell and object a long distance.
I would look at these high moving movers for example,
like risk curls or calf raises or shoulder shrugs.
They don't produce much power because you're not moving that much weight,
that long a distance.
So if you think about like for example,
key produce,
more power in a squat,
right?
All the way down,
all the way up the load on you,
right?
You're moving your body so far,
or can you produce more power the calf raise,
right?
So at first recommend,
hey,
let's look at doing these type of movements like a thruster,
right?
Or a burpee verse,
a Bicep Curl,
right?
And the application that's associated.
Secondly,
let's look at your range of motion.
So if you're going to say you're gonna do a squat,
right?
Let's not go to here.
Let's try and take the crease of the hip or the knee joint.
We are knee was designed as a hinge.
So when I sit on a low toilet,
I can get back up again without having to use my hands.
Right.
Hard to do.
I'm sure if you've been,
Zeus had some time in Asia,
there's like everybody's really comfortable down in this kind of position,
which is right in Japan.
They go uncle Swati,
which is the shit spot.
But uh,
yeah,
you don't have dip bars to help you get out of that position.
So I was,
I saw a woman,
I was on an airplane yesterday and she had a really tough time getting the chair
and like I helped her out of the chair,
ray,
of course.
But my thing is,
you know,
a program that we do should help us outside the gym,
right?
Whatever I do in here,
shit most benefit me for outside the gym said this recommends the quality of
life that I'm looking for forever.
And there's certain movements that has don't carry over very well.
Right.
And there's certain ones that carry over really well,
like the dead lift,
the squat in the press.
Uh,
would you mind,
we talked a little bit about the back squat.
Would you mind showing us what a proper front squat it looks like?
Maybe if you wouldn't mind facing out this way and it's a little unnatural,
but yeah,
I'm very curious to see what a proper front it looks like they're,
there's,
so how to think about when you introduce that?
Yes,
there's several different types of squats,
right?
You have the overhead squat,
the front squat,
the back squat,
and then just basically the,
there's other types too,
right?
High Bar,
low bar,
this,
that.
But the point is is that each,
each one loads the system a little bit differently.
So take an overhead squat,
you're putting that load way over your head.
So now what happens is this,
this object is now so far away from your center of mass that it puts more
momentum,
more,
more force onto your midline to control it like a wrench.
If you had a small wrench,
right?
It doesn't create that much torque people,
long wrench creates a lot of torque.
So the overhead squat,
it's Kinda like the king for that.
But in regards to the front squat,
one of the,
one of the benefits of the front squat and one of the reasons why I love it is
for again the carryover.
Why?
Because we receive a clean here,
we do thrusters here.
There's a lot more carryover in this position.
So one of the things that I do if I'm front squatting,
right,
cause I focused on just be aware of that.
But like my,
my go down for the count,
we'll see.
We got three small fingers,
right?
What I'm looking for right is barely to keep my fingers on this bar because
eventually if I'm death gripping it,
which is fine,
I can't get the bar as high up in my throat.
So what I'm looking for,
right,
just putting the pads of your finger on it.
Yeah.
So I'll,
I'll warm it up,
right?
I'll make sure my lats are warmed up in here and this is really what's tight.
So a lot of people complain about risk payment needed front squats.
The reason why they complain about that so they can't get their elbow up.
So we think about it,
the risk flection is not any further than if you just did a push up on the
floor.
But in reality,
what it really actually is,
is your lats being so tight that you can't get your elbow in a position to then
open you up.
Do you warm up your lats or,
or ensure the of the proper range of motion in your lats with anything other
than this particular type of world where,
where'd you find this to be enough?
I find this to be enough salt.
I'll go back and forth.
I'll put the bar on my shoulder,
right?
And I'll start working it out.
So let's just say I'm in here right now.
I'm kind of working,
it can open up.
I would take a little bit time here,
right?
Yep.
And then,
you know what I mean?
A minute,
two minutes,
a minute.
And you know,
you can also go up to the bar,
you can open up your lats by just holding onto the bar and kind of dragging your
head through the window.
Right?
Well,
let's just see.
You're in here now.
A lot of people,
we want to death grip it and do this,
right?
The problem with this is right now I'm supporting it and it's like carrying
groceries in,
in,
in the store.
If I carry groceries out here,
it's can be really hard for carry groceries rep against my really easy.
Same thing applies here.
So the bar is right up against my throat,
right?
What I'm focused on is I want to think like there's basically laser beams coming
at the ends of my elbows.
As I squat,
I want those laser beams to plant the wall in front of me.
And the reason for that is the hierarchy of my elbows.
The more the bars that against my throat,
the closer is my center of mass,
the lighter it's going to make the object.
Hm.
So as to send down the exact same thing,
right?
I would sit back into it,
Elbows up in this position.
Boom,
exact same thing.
But really the key here,
right?
Loose grip,
elbows up over the lat to get there.
And uh,
if you had to pick or wanted to pick,
say front squat or overhead squat,
would you choose the front squat or do you find for overall benefit and transfer
the,
the overhead squat to be in some way?
I would say for night,
for most people I'd recommend back squat,
right then front squat because it's a little bit harder to get into a good
position on a friend's car and he's going to back squat.
It requires some time.
Yeah,
right.
Another drill and it was kind of open for last,
right here.
Right.
So what I would say is back spots king then Francois,
cause I think it has a huge carryover prom mistakes,
limited time,
get to open up the lats now at the overhead squat,
right.
One of the problems we see with the overhead squat,
oops,
that was my big shoulder mobility,
right?
So if your shoulders are tight,
skinny,
very challenging for you to sit up here
and squat down,
right?
Because there's so many things.
I mean,
if you look at my position,
right?
The bars over my head as I descend down,
Naturally this bar,
and he's a sales my center of mass.
So what I do,
I pull the bar back a little bit.
Not My shoulders are tight.
One of the problems I have there is I can't get the bar back,
so then I end up doing this.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Very challenging.
Smarick munitions,
back squat,
front squat,
overhead squat.
Some you should do,
you should start with a PVC pipe over your shoulders,
uh,
down,
whatever,
and then get there.
Cool.
Thank you sir.
Hope you enjoyed the video.
If you would like to see my favorite piece of content that I put out every week,
it is a short newsletter.
Five bullet Friday.
It's free.
It's five bullet points with the coolest things that I have been finding using
testing in a given week.
I put it out every Friday.
You can digest it in about five minutes.
Take a look.
Bible of Friday.